I know why you're happy no more
political ads on TV isn't that why I
tell you that the end it was like only
political ads right for weeks I have
never been so happy to see the Cialis
couple back in their [ __ ] bathtub
[Applause]
first the downside with the election big
over is that the lawn signs go away
and then you can't tell which one of
your neighbors is an [ __ ] but the
election kind of a split decision
Democrats won the house Russia kept the
Senate and we found out that the divide
in this country is bigger than ever the
red rural parts came out overwhelmingly
for trunk the blue urban parts came out
against him we are really devolving into
two countries the the tobacco chewers
[Laughter]
and the people oh babe that's America
I don't know what's gonna happen but no
you know the election went well but it
wasn't everything we really hoped it was
that hard hit ball off the wall that
turns into a long single you know it was
red wine but from Trader Joe's a new car
but a Buick the the chicken dish at a
nice restaurant a [ __ ] you know just
not everything you were hoping for but
some some races are still undecided and
Republicans say it is not over until
each and every vote has been suppressed
so that's now the reason why I'm not
terribly optimistic is we have a new
Attorney General it's yeah have you seen
this guy it's the guy who snapped in
Full Metal Jacket
this this was after the photographer
said smile so I I call him curly because
he's the bald stooge
say what you want about Trump's other
big fans at least Cesar Seok took the
time to paint on some hair but this guy
Matthew Whitaker the new Attorney
General boy does he love him some Donald
Trump everything Whitaker has sent or
written just amplifies Trump's unhinged
narratives he wrote an op-ed which said
the Muller investigation goes too far he
wants to indict Hillary Clinton he's so
far up Trump's ass Hannity had just
scoot over
and before he got this job he was
involved with the company that defrauded
money from money from misfiring in
investors he was like the the hard guy
you you know beat it out of them
you know Trump lives in this opposite
world he puts criminals in charge of the
Justice Department facts are lies he's
awake when he should be asleep
he talks out of his ass but [ __ ] comes
out of his mouth
this guy Trump says he doesn't know
Matthew Whitaker we know Matthew
Whitaker's been to the Oval Office many
times we have a tape of Trump on tape
just from October saying Whitaker's a
great guy I mean I know Matthew Whitaker
sometimes I think Donald Trump is really
a set of twins there's Donald Trump and
Ronald Trump they're masquerading is the
same person but sometimes they just
can't get their story straight and
Republicans they don't care anymore
there's no such thing anymore as how it
looks they this election they elected to
indicted criminals and a dead pimp I'm
not making that up that should be the
punchline remember ba dead pimp no
that's the true part
and Duncan hunter from right down the
road here in California under indictment
he's been here nice guy criminal nice
guy his slogan was a man with
convictions
and then Democrats no luck last thing we
need this week Ruth Bader Ginsburg broke
three ribs she says she's gonna be okay
but that is the last time she parties
with Brett Kavanaugh that's
but
but let's end this monologue on a happy
note there was some good news let's not
bury that completely for the Democrats
diversity was a big winner on Tuesday
minorities more gay people and just to
screw with Trump they plan on arriving
in DC in a caravan also to Muslim women
are now in Congress it'll be great for
the world to see that and hear that to
Native Americans from New Mexico and my
favorite Kansas [ __ ] Ganz's Charisse
David's a lesbian mixed martial arts
fighter
let's see Trump call her Pocahontas